ouais alors j'ai utilisé ce sketch pour faire passer le
message aux parents
parce que ce sont eux qui aiment les
gens difficiles à leur dire de ne pas faire les
choses quand ils le regardent et ils rient
ils vont aussi se souvenir du
message d'accord la solution  à masa
oshi avec le même logo pour le juger pour
l'instant
[Musique]
c'est avec un grand mécontentement grande douleur que
je reçois Griffin arrêter Ebola une maladie de
Kurata réputée ce n'est pas traité
comme une maladie de seconde classe ce n'est pas mon
propos
[Musique]
alors  elle est allée voir la bouche nez les yeux
voici n'importe quelle protéine populaire c'est presque
comme s'ils pouvaient le faire maintenant ou faire
n'est pas juste pour une invention les animaux non
seulement ne plaisantaient plus qui
affecte réellement la vie et je pense que cette période
sera plus de vidéos  nous avons besoin d'un contexte plus commun,
les gens font des blagues parce que si vous le
faites en ligne, pardonnez-moi